while many Americans also head to the
beach in the summer others opt for camp
in our series the new normal we look at
how the pandemic is dramatically
changing our everyday lives coronavirus
concerns are forcing summer camps to
shut down all over the US that's a big
problem for kids and parents more than
14 million children adolescents and
adults a ten year for camps that do open
the CDC recommends they should enforce
the use of face masks clothes shared
spaces like dining halls and playgrounds
and keep campers in the same small
groups every day meg Oliver visited one
camp that will have a quiet summer
summer at YMCA Camp Mason in New Jersey
usually looks something like this
[Applause]
there's no such thing as social
distancing everything is about being
together until now for the first time in
120 years camp Mason will not open this
summer they decided to cancel before the
state mandated it have you ever
cancelled camp before the camp has been
through world wars floods other
pandemics and but this is unfortunately
the first year we've had to cancel
there are around 8400 overnight camps in
the US and each year the YMCA runs more
than 300 of them the American Camp
Association and the YMCA recently
released an 82 page guideline for camps
which includes how to decide if you
should open how to properly clean and
disinfect and how to handle a suspected
coronavirus case among campers or staff
why did you make the decision to cancel
most of our campers come from the five
boroughs of New York the larger towns
and cities of New Jersey and
internationally not only could have
posed health risks to our campers and
their families and our shared
communities but the changes that we
would have had to enact to operate camp
social distancing reduce numbers of
campers no group games it would have
made the camp experience on recognizable
unrecognisable for campers like
fifteen-year-old Angelina
Mack what does this camp mean to you
means everything it's what I look
forward to every single year
Angelina lives just outside Philadelphia
this would have been her seventh summer
at camp just like is so much better and
it's just completely green there's just
so much space to like go you can just go
free you think about summer with counsel
[Music]
for some parents like mother of four Meg
st. Esprit camp isn't just about getting
kids outdoors it's also practical she
and her husband work full-time in
reliant summer camps for some of their
child care famous breezes virtual camps
which are popping up across the country
are not much help my six-year-old twins
we've done a couple different test runs
of some different virtual classes their
attention span is just not quite there
yet I've been joking around my house
we're gonna have a 1970 summer CBS News
contributor and psychologist Lisa
d'amour advises parents think about the
day in parts which include assigned
activities and having kids create their
own agenda helping out around the house
part of the day you can watch TV you can
read you're gonna go get bored there
will be no technology available to you
in that time and you're gonna figure out
what to do with that time for kids like
Angelina figuring out what to do now is
their latest disappointment
what is your summer look like now that
you won't be able to come up here to
camp Mason well that was supposed to be
a month of my summer but now no one ever
expected not to have summer camp this
year but having taught kids grit having
taught kids resiliency over the years
you know they're gonna overcome this
they're gonna grow and they're gonna
continue to thrive for CBS this morning
Meg Oliver Hardwick New Jersey
see